38 13 comme il ya cinq ans et
je oui j'ai peur que voilà de de
repenser et de me dire voilà ce moment
là les piles cinq ans
j'ai un flash très précis quelques
secondes avant de recevoir la balle en
fête
donc là je vois l'inde est l'un des
terroristes en fait je me rappelle pas
toujours de ce visage en fait j'essaie
de trouver une porte de sortie
je vois que c'est ok les gens sont
entassés à côte une sortie donc jeu
j'essaye de trouver une autre voie enfin
qu'une autre issue et là je l'entends
donc le bruit de des balles ça me paraît
très violente puis d'un coup je suis
fauché littéralement fauché en fait par
terre enfin je me retrouve je me
retrouve par terre j'ai les oreilles qui
sifflent gt2 qui tourne je suis
complètement sonné et la voilà je
réalise en fait que s'est pris une balle
je regarde la jambe
ma jambe je vois là du sang partout je
sens que mes jambes complètement enfin
ne répond plus quoi fin je suis parterre
impossible d'enlever une douleur
indescriptible enfin nancy nantes
et puis pris au piège a eu aucun moyen
de mon allée heureusement vous voyez
quelqu'un de très courageux et je tiens
à remercier d'ailleurs ça parce que je
les ai jamais revus
mais qui a essayé de m'aider qui
maquille me porter de fait on a fait les
morts pendant fin jusqu'à la fin en fait
j'ai parlé avec elle quelques personnes
mais on chuchotait vraiment c'était
parce que la plupart des autres victimes
sont disent que je me suis dit pourquoi
enfin pourquoi maintenant pourquoi ça
nous arrive
comment est ce possible enfin deux sites
spécialisés sur la liste veut dire s'est
pas gêné dire qu'enfin tire sur des gens
désarmés
enfin sur dans une salle de concert
bourré soir dans le xixe arrondissement
parisien
c'est juste le diamètre de la balle donc
c'est juste une petite cicatrice mois
quasiment plein mais ce genre de balle
en fait tu exploses lorsqu'elles
pénètrent dans la chair donc ça en
revanche ça énormément de dommage et
l'intérieur de la jambe gauche
donc en fait je me suis retrouvé qu'un
trou de 15 cm de longueur et sur sur
quasiment dix centimètres tout a sauté
l'os les parties musculaire à pau enfin
tout ça pour finir que j'ai essayé ces
assises moment le plus fort un mot aussi
c'est la fin c'est quand j'entends les
tirs isolés
d'ailleurs les tyrans comme dix ans par
rafale mais voilà un par un donc moi je
pense tout de suite à une exécution en
fait donc je peux dire en gros le l'un
des terroristes pas dans les rangs pour
vérifier que tout le monde est mort en
fait dans la fosse au niveau des cas
donc là je me dis c'est la fin et voilà
et puis je repense à tous les faire tous
les gens que j'aime toute personne et
voilà je vois tous les visages et je
vois je pense à mes parents ma famille
c'est s'appuie en fait c'est
c'est penser à eux fait c'est de penser
à lui et on se dit ok voilà je vais vie
s'arrête ce soir at elle ajouté enfin je
vis victime de sa fin de cette manière
en plus c'est une sorte de moi donc moi
je me pose des questions voilà par
rapport à fin mai ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
devient qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
quand tu rugby mais qu'ont donc pas sur
ma gauche
comment ça se matérialise ce qui est une
forme de conscience et en fait ça vient
pas enfin ça m'a pas un seul n'a pas vu
cette explosion donc après j'ai su que
c'était voilà les commissaires de la bac
et son adjoint
j'ai compris qu'en fait il avait voilà
les murs d'état de nuire d'un des
terroristes et c'est pour ça qu'on était
encore vivant qu'on voit là que c'est
espoirs étaient encore permis
si je me vider mon sens et le temps a
paru très long très très long c'est jeu
mordelles
par exemple j'ai tellement mal je me
rendais le futur de la personne qui
était un tout moi et je ne savais pas
c'est est vivante ou décédée c'est une
douleur comptable et j'ai pas possible
je pouvais pas bouger de toute façon
mais je n'ai pas bougé d'un centimètre
pendant quelques heures et je ne sais
pas exactement lors qu'il était quand on
est sorti et me dire qu'ils étaient à
peu près minuit il a le trouve la force
j'étais déjà j'ai du mal
j'ai plus trop de force et l'effroi je
sais que j'ai perdu beaucoup de sang je
pense avoir des difficultés à respirer
suffoquait et je trouve la force
d'appeler ma mère parce que je pensais
en fait quelques il savait que j'étais
là bas et heureusement et ça c'était un
soulagement énorme ne le savaient pas
l'ignorer et donc c'est moi qui lui a
promis jeudi j'ai tout lu j'ai plus il
ya ça va je me laissais mais ça va je
suis vivant ça va beaucoup de chance
j'en suis conscient donc aujourd'hui la
vie reprend son cours j'y pense pas tout
le temps heureusement c'est mais ça fait
partie de moi puisque quelque chose qui
restera
il ya aussi une sensibilité qui auditive
par exemple tout ce qui est des
détonations même ne serait ce qu'une
porte qui claque parfois je ressens
encore ce jeu comme un réflexe en fait
d'eux des cas un bruit j'ai le réflexe
de tourner tout de suite la tête je suis
pas forcément encore totalement à l'aise
quand par exemple voilà je retourne à
des concerts j'adore sage et puis
retournez donc ça m'a fait du bien
et en même temps il y avait une forte
appréhension avant oui je peux le dire
je suis aujourd'hui c'est ça s'éloigne
c'est toujours présent mais voilà on est
cinq ans après la reconstruction a été
longue
si bien physiquement que
psychologiquement j'ai mis deux ans et
demi pour me remettre physiquement parce
que j'ai des rechutes j'ai eu
j'ai plusieurs opérations 8 après j'ai
eu dix anesthésie générale en tout et
puis en fait j'ai pu vraiment remarcher
quasiment normalement mais avec une
canne à partir de
j ai pris d'effroi
c'est l'impression cinq ans après s'il
voit tire un bilan
oui j'ai pas l'impression que les choses
ont beaucoup évolué et là dessus on ne
combattra pas ça pardon mais en mettant
des bougies et je pense qu est trop naïf
en fait par rapport à ce genre
d'individus quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des établissements de déradicalisation
pardon mais ça m'a paru complètement à
côté de la plaque je vois pas comment
comment les gens pouvaient sincèrement
croire que ce genre d'individus
pourraient pour se repentir
combien de morts ou de blessés combien
de vies brisées par voile à cause de ça
donc non la forme de pardon j'ai envie
de croque le pardon se mérite ont fait
et je l'aimé car j'ai trop d'image -
trop d'imagés trop de trop de souffrance
et je pense que c'est un combat c'est un
combat qu'il faut mener donc si on
pardonne tout enfin
ça recommencera
[Musique]